hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast community-acquired bacterial
pneumonia a 2016 perspective I am
Christina jewel of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented and sponsored by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
for more information go to ww routes
comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
grand Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window when Friday
answer as many questions as you can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner at the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem disagreeing Q&A button nor
we left this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CC button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Glen to Lofton Glen is a senior vice
president at sempra incorporated in
chapel hill united states of america he
is trained in medical microbiology and
infectious diseases and almost 30 years
of pharmaceutical industry experience in
various areas including clinical
research commercialization scientific
communication including publication
planning strategic drug development
lifecycle management and global launch
programs Glen has been instrumental in
the
development of cipralex ciprofloxacin
and moxifloxacin as well as drugs enough
as other drugs in the Bayer portfolio
for whom he worked for 15 years he later
worked for optimum pharmaceuticals as
senior vice president of medical affairs
and built a team to support the launch
aphid aksam icin dip it did the first
new antibiotic for speed episode in over
20 years one is a member of the
scientific steering committee for the
gtc bio annual summit on anti-infective
partnering as well as the Emerald
Society he has also passed chair of the
accp Executive Council of networks and a
member of a CCP I apologize he is past
chair of the accp chest infection
network and a member of the acct
executive council of networks in 2009
Glenn was honored by the American
College of chest physicians with the
Alfred Stouffer award for contributions
to the college going to Vaughn several
journal editorial advisory boards
including the lancet infectious disease
and f1000 I will now turn it over to dr.
to lessen for his presentation dr. to
Lawson
not sure ah we go trying to find my
slides well I'm hopeful hopefully
everybody is able to hear me hello I'm
not going to say good morning or good
afternoon so I'm going to speak for the
next 40 minutes or so about
community-acquired bacterial pneumonia
interestingly this term has evolved in
the United States over the last few
years from community acquired pneumonia
cap was when he was referred to it which
is caused by both bacterial and viral
pathogens however about six seven years
ago 2009 the fda issued guidance which
will help us distinguish between the
organism to the court of ammonium
whether they bacterial or viral and
really this was an effort to address the
concerns about antibiotic resistance so
i will generally refer to the term c abp
if I slots into cap please forgive me so
what is community-acquired pneumonia I'm
sure many of you on the webex of heard
of pneumonia community-acquired is
different from hospital acquired and so
forth but basically community-acquired
pneumonia is where you acquire an
infection of the pulmonary irregular
that's part of your lung and it's an
acute infection basically means you've
acquired those pathogens in the
community not the hospital typically
this is accompanied by the presence of a
what's called an infiltrate and I'll
show you an infiltrating a few moments
on a chest x-ray but as a physician if
you listen to someone's chest you can be
wheezing rattling most of Sevilla
auscultatory findings and those are
consistent with pneumonia and to be
community-acquired pneumonia you should
not have been hospitalized or in a
long-term care facility to the prior
couple of weeks
how does not pneumonia manifest itself
well typically you'll have a temperature
you have the shakes the rykors you'll
sweat and he will cough you may produce
sputum you may not and usually if you
produce sputum it's a glorious color
that I won't describe too much but then
their other symptoms such as fatigue or
tiredness muscle pains abdominal pain
which you think about if you're coughing
a lot you get abdominal pain so on the
screen you will see a variety of other
symptoms that we would use to guide
toward diagnosis account you can see
there on his chest x-ray circled area on
the left hand side the right lower lobe
as you can see it that is an
infiltration that is where they the
x-rays are unable to penetrate through
to the blackness that you can see for
the rest of the longer that white patch
is bad news now chest x-rays positive
like this may be due to infection may
have other causes but in addition to the
things I've just mentioned fever and so
forth you start to build up a picture
the cheeks all cap one of the risk
factors for developing
community-acquired pneumonia well age
and those over the age of 60 have a
higher tendency and proclivity to
actually developing the ammonia
alcoholism alcoholism does things to
your immune system so again that's a
risk factor smoking I don't need to
mention that conditions like asthma and
further Daniel cecile meeting obviously
those cause your lungs to be defective
in some way allowing the access of
organisms bacteria or viruses immune
suppression that's an obvious problem
institutionalization there you come into
contact with a range of different
bacteria and if you're institutionalized
there's a chance that you've got some
other risk factor bottom of the list by
no means the least dimension again
that's associated with host defense
reductions what causes pneumonia
community quite lean on well there is
one organism that we've known about for
probably about 200 years streptococcus
pneumoniae originally called diplococcus
pneumonia I'll show you a picture of
what that looks like in a few moments
but pretty much wherever you manifest
your pneumonia streptococcus pneumonia
is the main bacterial cause and you can
see here I broadened the location to
where you manifest your disease our
patient primary care setting which
really is the plastic majority community
greatly nahmias the inpatient where
you're admitted to the local hospital or
if you really sick you go to the
intensive care unit and you can see the
top pathogen for all of those is
strictly money and then it varies a
little mycoplasma demopolis whereas on
the inpatient I see you you seem all
organisms like Staphylococcus aureus
Legionella and then the gram negatives
like klebsiella and e-coli so hopefully
for those listening and watching you
familiar with many of these bacterial
names and although I've ranked them at
the bottom the respiratory viruses also
obviously must not be neglected here and
talk about things will ends of iris
rhinovirus corona and adenovirus so
those play a role and community quietly
moaning and in a number of cases are
will be around thirty percent you will
actually have two veins causing your
pneumonic condition now it has been said
that the symptoms and so forth that you
present we are in suggestive of a
certain type of pathogen I'm sorry to
burst that bubble but really research
over many many years as refute would
refute the clinical signs and symptoms
and epidemiological features guide you
to a pathogen I think there are there's
a really need for for microbiology
confirmation so one of the lab tests
that you would do to confirm
community-acquired pneumonia well first
of all you take a blood sample look for
white blood cells those should be
elevated and by that time talking ten
twelve fifteen thousand sort of white
blood count you should obtain a good
quality sputum sample
you're a grand film you see one of those
in a moment if the patient goes to
hospital or is quite sick in the
community you should take blood clenches
preferably to set two locations to make
sure that you know what's isolated from
the blood is a genuine cause of
bacteremia bloodstream infections you
can also take a sample of urine and
because of streptococcus pneumoniae and
also legionella pneumophila the the ab
two coats of those bacteria actually are
excreted in your urine you can actually
detect both of those pathogens in a
urinary test which obviously is
relatively convenient but how about in
all of this that just discussed is
actually getting the good quality sputum
sample and the good quality sputum
sample should be predominantly pus cells
and put cells if you look at the leaf
run film that you can see on the screen
those time of those cells that have got
multiple multinucleated cells those are
a white blood cells pus cells and you
can see lots of small deep purple little
spots around those you'll notice that
many of them seem to be in pairs well
those are diplo cocci that is a very
good image of sputum with streptococcus
pneumoniae causing an ammonium and we
strive to get good quality samples
because often the production and we call
expectations commutative travels through
your mouth and we need to reduce the
amount of oral mouth flora so that what
we see is really what's causing your
problem and there as I say you've got a
very good example of pneumococcal
pneumonia so I've told you what the how
the disease manifests and what causes
the disease clearly one of the things
that we wanted it with
community-acquired bacterial pneumonia
is to prescribe an antibiotic and up
until the sort of the 1940s we didn't
have that benefit and some of the older
ways and treating you mallya were quite
radical from the 1940s we have any silly
it's moving on from there but as some of
you may remember Fleming in receiving
his Nobel Prize commented that bacteria
will sooner or later work out to become
resistant so I'm going to for that if
you want to speak about bacteria and
their resistance to certain antibiotics
or antimicrobials we have good data in a
variety of locations around the world
I'm going to focus on the u.s. because i
think you know we can tell you a good
coherent consistent story for the
equally provide data for europe and also
for patient but focusing on the u.s.
focused here on streptococcus me money I
just looking at macrolide resistance the
reason I focused on macrolides is that
that would be a drug line erythromycin
clarithromycin azithromycin those are
the common want in the u.s. in Europe
their honor to other macrolides
available but stretton you know is the
number one pathogen and macrolide or
doxycycline are the recommended drugs
from the 80s and idsa guidelines for
treating low risk low risk outpatient
ammonius which actually constitute a
very large proportion of your community
quietly bonus so you can see over the
last 15 or so years macrolide resistance
in pneumococci has gone from just over
thirty percent now to almost fifty
percent not a broad picture across the
USA now if you recall 23 years ago CBC
here in the USA was particularly
concerned about antibiotic resistance
and came up with a better phrase a
league table and depending upon how
serious the threat was they had bc
leasing listed these different pathogens
and streptococcus pneumoniae found a
position on that in the urgent category
and here are some facts and figures
hopefully you could see them clear
enough but trim resistant streptococcus
pneumoniae we've got seven thousand
deaths excess medical costs excess
hospitalizations it's pretty evident the
drug resistant pneumococci are a major
burden and a major challenge
when you're thinking about empirical
therapy and that's what most positions
have to do kneecap they don't have the
luxury of sophisticated laboratories and
that sort of approach they have to treat
with an antibiotic pretty quickly so CDC
field that streptococcus pneumoniae is a
challenge it's not just microlight but
there are other antibiotics that have
resistance issues and you can see on the
left hand side here the distance rates
to some of the other frequently use
antibiotics just to give you an idea of
you know this train has left the station
antibiotic resistance in the US has
continued to be a problem and I'm sure
many of you on though on the webex will
appreciate that we have President
Obama's PCAST and a whole host of other
initiatives to manage antibiotic
resistance here you can see some data
presented about 18 months ago which
looked at streptococcus pneumoniae
susceptibility to the common
antimicrobials over a four-year period
and you can see that all of them each of
the classes of antibiotics examined
whether it's penicillin ampicillin moxa
club erythromycin tetracycline chromatic
install from the doctors all or far
right levofloxacin all of them have
shown a decrease in susceptibility ie
can increase in resistance over the last
four years and I think this is typical
of what's going on out there in the
community it's important though that we
we ensure that describers and patients
actually understand the importance of
this however antibiotic resistance is
not homogeneous and if you look at this
nut with the USA you can see the
heterogeneity in pneumococcal resistance
here I've chosen to macrolides
erythromycin is the parent of the class
but more recently clarithromycin and
specifically cuz it's nice a bit on the
major macrolides of preference but you
can see looking at the map here at the
end of the USA you can see that over in
the Far West Pacific and the mountain
region
the resistance rate is around thirty
forty percent you would confer the ease
and you can see that in the central and
over to the the Atlantic coast the
resistance rate increases quite markedly
in fact in Texas and Alabama and down in
Dalton both states were over sixty
percent with the pneumococci are
resistant to one of the most commonly
prescribed antibiotics which is a little
bit of an empirical concern my product
resistance is not unique to the USA if
you look at the red line which is
twenty-five percent resistance you know
North America from this data is above
the red line you're a depending where
you are in Europe the average is
twenty-eight percent but that could
differ between different countries Spain
Italy and Greece I've got levels more
akin to the US and forty percent you go
to the Far East victor Asia and more
specifically to China you're looking at
seventy to ninety percent resistance
which are quite significant levels of
resistance to us again and say this is
the most one of the most commonly
prescribed classes of antibiotics so we
appreciate that what new Manya is how it
presents what does it look like with we
know that commute acquired pneumonia
requires antibiotic treatment since some
of the issues with regard to resistance
because resistance matter is does it
have any burden for the next few slides
I'm going to show you some of the things
that were able to measure in terms of
new-mown here is an illness so for
example it is quite prevalent and by
that annually in the United States nine
million prescriptions are dispensed for
what would be called it an icd-10 coded
as of ammonium over a million patients
annually are hospitalized there's almost
five million visits the primary care
doctor well they're equivalent and as I
mentioned at the start of my
presentation the older patients are
affected disproportionately and it was
all slow that
I had pneumonia as the old man's friend
basically meant you know the older
person who has is debilitated and is
looking for a way out pneumonia was
often a way out it's been estimated that
the cost in the USA alone is in excess
of 10 billion dollars a year purely due
to pneumonia and if you're concerned
about his new Monier a cause of
mortality you look to the right hand
side the histogram their shows at
pneumonia account for more deaths than
either breast or prostate cancer I think
that's a fairly significant impact I
mentioned that over a million patients
are hospitalized here you can see
increasing numbers of visits to the
emergency department in England would
call it the casualty department but now
almost 3.3 million people will go to the
emergency room because of pneumonia
that's a lot of hospital visit
potentially could be avoided if you then
look at hospital admissions or
admissions to the intensive care unit
I'm sure you all agree chest pain and
congestive heart failure are two of the
more obvious and expected reasons for
going to hospital but over half a
million patients will be admitted to us
hospitals if you want or something
similar to remain you long we're looking
here at about almost four percent of all
intensive care admissions sadly even
though we try to treat these patients
appropriately with the right antibiotics
about fifteen percent of them will come
back into hospital because of their
Yemanja so it really is important to
recognize these patients recognize their
risk factors and treat them
appropriately as soon as you can so in
medicine nowadays blue light guidelines
will I routes and algorithms to make
sure we manage our patients probably and
surprisingly we have a range of
different society guidelines to help us
manage is this maze of bacterial and
viral infections and in fact they think
grouped into the better treatment is
true in the current guidelines or is it
it just give you a little bit of feel
what tends to happen in primary care
where there's large numbers of of
pneumonia cases antibiotics have been
used in a workhorse capacity many
physicians adopter sorting conservative
attitude and go low go slow typer branch
and they think about these new powerful
really potent drugs they only use those
that the patients that are not
responding however a theory hypothesis
was proposed in 1913 by Paul Ehrlich and
his philosophy was to hit hard and hit
early now this is actually 20 years
before the advent of antibiotics from
DOMA but nevertheless he called it
chemother through 1913 Powell early k
APPA d4 a pay-for at a flat David which
is hit hard and hit girl with an
appropriate antibiotic and if you use
the right antibiotic and he works in a
killing fashion then you should be able
to work for just the right period of
time kill the bacteria get out so short
duration of treatment and where
appropriate you can scale them now a
number of patients will have to
associate said before go to the
emergency department may well be
admitted to the hospital which case
those are sick patients and those sick
patients deserve some more prompt and
aggressive therapy perhaps a parental
therapies like an intravenous so you can
start off with intravenous therapy and
when they've stabilized and I'll talk a
little bit about that in a few moments
you can then they turned into an immoral
education maybe you can send them home
when most people get better soon them so
what do we have currently
or community-acquired leave on you well
nine years ago was a joint effort from
the infectious disease Society of
America and the American Thoracic
Society they broke out pneumonia into
various components and mrs.
community-acquired pneumonia it's not
hospital-acquired healthcare-associated
these are referring to community quietly
money and far left previously healthy
these are people with no underlying
disease generally younger patient but
not always and if they're not had an
antibiotic in the prior three months for
anything then a macrolide or
tetracycline doxycycline are the
recommended choices however the IDSA
also said that any region where
antibiotic resistance amongst
pneumococci the number one bacterial
cause if that resistance rate exceeds
25% then you need to find an alternative
now I didn't show you earlier the
tetracycline resistance rates in the US
but they're presently around 27 28 sent
something like that so for the
previously healthy no antibiotics in
prior three months macrolide resistance
is approaching fifty percent in the u.s.
doxycycline resistance is over
twenty-five percent your options are
reduced if though a patient has got
comorbidities by that I mean COPD asthma
some of the things I call risk factors
earlier or you know they're just general
if you think they need more help you can
use what's called a respiratory
fluoroquinolone and the three members of
that group this levofloxacin
moxifloxacin and Jenny floxacin or you
can use a combination for beta lactam
which is amoxicillin I suppose is
probably one of the the best recognize
of the beta lactams and my providing why
would you use that combination well it's
like times are pretty good for it for
sorry for some of the pneumococci but
they're not very good against the
atypical species like mycoplasma
Legionella or rarely chlamydia that's
where the microwave
blacklight most of those quite well
although in the USA we are seeing
mycoplasma your money I with micro ohm
resistance starting to emerge so as you
can see some of your options are a
little bit limiting nowadays but if you
look to the Far Far around here we have
to think about stretch macro allison
streptococcus pneumonia and consider
using alternative agents such as surface
boring or possibly doxycycline if you're
in an area where you know the resistance
rates are lower that's what you do in
the community but if you go to the
hospital what do you do well if you go
to the general ward to the floor as in
South can call here so this is a sick
patient but not really sick then you
would give them a respiratory
fluoroquinolone just described or the
beta lactam and the macro line so pretty
much what you saw as the call morbidity
regimen but use this in in the hospital
as I say most people if they go into
hospital would receive it an intravenous
dose or two to start with so it's an old
adage Union the other thing is that sick
patients generally don't tolerate oral
drugs well and their absorption is a bit
unpredictable if though the patient is
seriously ill and that's usually high
white count I fever right boys and so
forth they go to the intensive care unit
and here again he would use beta-actin I
would probably expect multiply six to
use a drug called ceftriaxone and they
would also use it City mice both
available as IVs or you could use the
same Peter laptop settlers etc tri-axial
with a fluoroquinolone so those are the
options where you don't suspect some of
the really difficult pathogens and have
not really focused on pseudomonas
aeruginosa and so forth that really is
more for a talk on hospital quietly
knock those pathogens do occur in
community-acquired pneumonia but less
than two percent of the time
mentioned before about duration of
treatment well here are some other
guidelines that have been published
actually one or two since the the
American guidelines BTS the British
thoracic society and the ers the
European aspire to society and you can
see there's a little bit of variability
here in the US we say patient should be
treated for a minimum of five days but
in order to stop therapy they really
should have had no temperature I a
febrile for two to three days and you
really shouldn't have any of the
symptoms of pneumonia still indicating
the clinical instability if you feel
that the patient has got a underlying
core modern condition or if they're in
identified to having some form of what
we call extra pulmonary infection such
as meningitis or a bloodstream infection
then you clearly treat for as long as
the patient requires it as I said
earlier you're looking for clinical
stability in Britain again look at the
visa disease severity and the therapy
she continued for 7 to 21 days and the
21 days really comes from from they be
all ways of managing Legionella disease
and then at the bottom the ers a
basically said duration treatment should
generally not exceed paydays back to the
same that gives you a little bit of room
for manoeuvre so what are the issues
currently the treating
community-acquired bacterial pneumonia
and you can see here that described the
primary options settle sporrans with a
macrolide or sponsor fluoroquinolone and
then some of the issues that you can see
see here some drugs don't have an oral
option even though they're very potent
IV and it may be that some of the micro
Lites that you use just have the the
gaps in their spectrum that you would be
concerned about equal as some of the
other antibiotics have got an adverse
event profile that is is less than
optimal you need to be concerned about
some of the condition some of the things
like Clostridium difficile
as you heard from the introduction
that's something unfamiliar with you
also need to be concerned about tendon
ruptures some of the cardiac issues that
it ever occur without antibiotics and
obviously community-acquired pneumonia
also affects children so you need to
think about that option as well so
choosing antibiotic is not just as
simple as reaching for the prescription
pad not that anyone does that anymore
it's all click click on you into
computer but it's much more complex than
just reaching prescribing think I just
mentioned about the formulation and
duration of therapy here are some of the
criteria that one would think about
changing from IV to oral so improvement
in coffin breathlessness your
temperatures dropped two time points
hopefully your white cell count is
diminishing and you've got a functioning
good that would allow you to take an
oral drug and that is is then absorbed
and you can see some of the other
reasons for wanting to switch to all
treatment mentioned just now have some
of the safety concerns antibiotics by
their very nature are toxic fortunately
you have more toxic to bacteria into
humans each the antibiotic classes we
use nowadays and I've chosen three heat
classes here just to give you some
examples but I could give you more
examples about the tech cycling's folate
antagonists and so forth but of the
three major classes they're using in
community-acquired bacterial pneumonia
and would focus on the big three so
macrolides in terms of things you as a
prescriber should be concerned about our
things that we would be warned or having
precautions about hypersensitivity i'm
sure you all understand us having an
allergic reaction to to the center of
hepatotoxicity refers to liver
dysfunction one form or another most of
the time transient it's not a problem
but it does occur QT prolongation is a
cardiac event again most of the time
it's not a problem but every now and
then yes the combination but then the
more common things that you associate
with most antibiotics are things like
diarrhea no
abdominal pain and vomiting and really
if you think about it you've taken the
medicine it's sat in your stomach I need
to probably pay playing havoc with your
normal bowel flora amongst other things
so those are the typical macrolide
events quinolones you see a different
array of issues here and I'm sure some
of you have heard some of the recent
warnings and remarks from the US FDA on
this then you can see here on the left
some of the things that are more
prevalent with fluoroquinolones and
coming from a background of developing
cipro and moxifloxacin some of these are
familiar to say the least CNS events
like dizziness and confusion tendon
issues again back to the cardiac QT
prolongation hypersensitivity that can
occur with almost any truck but does
occur with fluoroquinolones neuropathies
and then c diff and again at the bottom
common things such as GI upsets nausea
vomiting and obviously because of the c
diff there are some diarrheal problems
and then to round out the event seen
with the common drugs fetal items and by
this and talking about amoxicillin
clavulanic acid to the settles for ins
like cefuroxime axetil and also
ceftriaxone so here we're concerned
hypersensitivity Clostridium difficile
and again particularly in some of the
parental cephalosporins you see an
element of a butter toxicity at the
bottom diarrhea nausea but also with
Peter lanterns you see an incidence of
Russia's sometimes those rashes can be
really unpleasant quite painful so it's
probably the burden ammonia and we've
talked about the resistance rating
pneumococcal pneumonia obviously in this
day and age we are concerned about the
economic implications you know the
health system costs quite a lot of money
and as an individual we want to make
sure that the we're getting the right
treatment at the right time well
hopefully the right sort of cost so I'm
going to show you a couple of studies
here that they talk about what were the
impacts of actually
treating community-acquired pneumonia
with different drugs and in this case
focused on macrolide resistance and
really looking at what happens when you
have a threshold you may recall from
earlier that the IDSA recommended the
different area has more than 25 percent
resistance to a certain type of
antibiotic macrolides that you need to
look for an alternative therapy they be
doing that because they were concerned
about clinical failure we can take back
then to terms of dollars and cents there
are some quite significant issues here
and this is an elegant piece of work by
Carla ash and called published in the
Journal of antimicrobial therapy clinics
are alerted on that but I'm not going to
read through all of what you see here
but in essence they collected data from
water called metropolitan statistical
areas which in essence means big cities
and they concentrated the data on
patients who are 18 and over and they've
had a colleague they were recognized in
diagnosed as having pneumonia and they
received now departed within seven days
not surprisingly this study the average
age was around 48 years old half roughly
male female and how just over half of
them 56% lived in MSA a city area where
the resistance written below 25 percent
but remember this was a study that was
concluded in 2005 and in the intervening
nine years things have changed quite a
bit so what ash encoded they actually
compared the Ares with higher than
twenty-five percent resistance and those
lower you can see here this is clinical
failure clinical success thirteen
percent failure in the greater than
twenty-five percent grown and eighty
percent in the wrist in 25 and that was
a significant difference in terms of
clinical failure as you can see p value
there in the green box less than point
zero zero one so that is a clinical
failure so what I use does this really
matter
here we're looking at the dollar stinker
so again on the left-hand side greater
than twenty-five percent and you can see
where there's a treatment success in the
blue 2000 just over two thousand dollars
but in a resistance twenty-five percent
and greater failure cost was almost four
thousand dollars less than twenty-five
percent again was better to have a
treatment success just over thirteen
hundred dollars but even a trimmer
failure in the more susceptible area was
around twenty eight hundred dollars so
in prima failures about news or
treatment failures in resistance areas
are even more bad news so you know we're
converting here clinical failure
clinical success more expensive outcomes
altogether and again this has been looks
like you know variety health care
utilization and looking at specifically
drug-resistant needs straightening money
I and here we're looking at the health
utilization costs and here they were
looking at specifically different types
of antimicrobial resistance so we have
penicillin resistance erythromycin
microlight and fluoroquinolone systems
and again looking at pneumococcal
pneumonia and so we have four bars here
erythromycin resistance on the farm are
left and it's still in resistance
fluoroquinolone and then we have
multidrug resistance either erythromycin
and palestinian resistance or
combination of the three which is
uncommon but you can see that the direct
costs or erythromycin resistance or
multidrug resistance are very similar
just under 100 million or thereabouts
but the gill of indirect costs the
overall burden antibiotic resistance in
strep pneumonia is pretty significant
it's often those sort of numbers that
are not factored into the overall
picture of the impact of
community-acquired bacterial pneumonia
and if you look in the bottom box there
the cost of antibiotic resistance was
estimated 91 million but 233 million
when
including work and practice productivity
loss remember not everybody that gets
the ammonium is over the age of 65
there's still a large chunk of
working-age people in there and the
incremental medical cost was actually
related to hospitalization due to
erythromycin resistance so if you can
avoid reduced the microlight resistance
there is a likelihood you may be able to
impact some of the adverse medical
implication and hospitals a shin and
virtual screen visits a massive effect
so why no antibiotics fail in treating
community-acquired pneumonia well the
diagnosis may be wrong and there's a
whole bunch of reasons I think it said
earlier on you can have a positive chest
x-ray but you may not be infected so you
need to pull together some of the other
signs and symptoms along with your chest
x-ray the other issue is that somebody
may have been rapidly deteriorating
their clinical condition was it was just
as we would say in England the patient's
going off and you did not get them to
the emergency to the intensive care unit
enough and that can have a dire
consequences a bacterial point of view
we have this discordant on mismatch
between the resistance or the antibiotic
susceptibility and the anticipated
pathogen and there and referring to
strep pneumo is the number one pathogen
but you need to know your local
resistance rates in order to avoid this
type of mismatch on the basilic side you
may have less of a consideration then
you would in perhaps the south central
areas so always be aware of your local
conditions and it may be that you've
been into hospital for some other reason
and you've developed what's called a
super infection and a nose of corneal
super infection I guess Clostridium
difficile would be the most obvious one
the the therapeutic part of this is that
you didn't use enough drug you underdose
the drug so you know I supposed to be
simplistic about it in
a 100-pound or lady may require less of
an antibiotic and a 300 pound linebacker
you know maybe my exaggerating little
there but we do need to think about what
Craig we give to whom and we also need
to think about how long we give it so
again insufficient treatment duration I
know we're all anxious to stop the
antibiotics as soon as we can but we
shouldn't overdo that trying to pull
this all together if we talked into
physicians and nurses and other
practitioners you'd be surprised right
the awareness of lack of awareness about
how deadly serious community-acquired
bacterial pneumonia race and the impact
that this disease has on important
things such as morbidity mortality and
healthcare system costs antibiotic
resistance does pose a challenge to
treating cab effectively and the current
treatment options really at the current
point if the physicians a dilemma they
have to trade off between drug efficacy
or well does it work and what can be
prevented potential downfalls in terms
of of safely so in conclusion eventually
quite back to hurry morning is a common
debilitating illness it tends to affect
the elderly patients disproportionately
it gives have a marked mortality in the
elderly I didn't dwell on that point but
you know the older patient do you can
die more frequently antibiotic existence
is a global issue conclude in the USA
but it varies within the USA bacteria
really don't know any boundaries they'll
migrate where they need to migrate so
knowing what's going on locally as well
as nationally is important before you
start to prescribe an antibiotic I think
we've seen reasonable evidence to
suggest that some of the standard
first-line agents are losing their
efficacy or they may still be
efficacious well there are other things
to consider before prescribing those
drugs I think currently the guidelines
for community-acquired pneumonia you
just need to comment I think we're all
aware that there is an updating progress
you can check out the RDS
hidss a website to get to today's on
that and but to conclude I think all
experts recognize the bacterial
resistance it's costly in a variety of
different ways and we really do need new
agents quite a virgin too thank you very
much indeed sure if I supposed to do dr.
Tyson thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can k dr.
to Moxon our first question is why don't
companies develop more inhaled
antibiotics as long as we're the
majority of infections respiratory
happens
live among you there are some challenges
when when one thinks about how to
actually deliver an inhale antibiotic in
the community setting that would be
quite the challenge quite often these
patients are either on ventilators or
require major medical and nursing
support in order to get to get the right
sort of delivery so inhaled antibiotics
seemed a good option and as I say there
are reminded by cosines and quinolones
being developed for pneumonia it's
generally nosocomial or Hospital
hospital ago had pneumonia I hope that
answers your question ok ok
sorry for the delay we're experiencing
just a little bit of technical
difficulty but we got this under control
next question how significant is the
p-value okay the p-value generally one
would say that anything that's got a
p-value of less than point 05 is
significant so I think I quoted a
p-value min presentation point zero zero
one in layman's terms that's quite
significant and I think you know if you
look for four values that are less than
point zero five oh you know I think
you're starting to believe the
credibility of a of a of an
investigation p values are below that
perhaps p less than point zero one so I
hope that answers the statistical
question please forgive me I'm not a
statistician I just try to use the P
values that are given to me so oh my
next question doctor to Watson is any is
there any way to use the existing
antibiotics without generating
persisters very good question and I
think because we have already developed
quite a population of persistent or
resistant bacteria it's going to be
quite the uphill challenge to over to
reverse that trend there have been
population experiments along those lines
over the last 30 to 40 years but known
to my knowledge have been successful it
requires a draconian approach to
antibiotic use and because we tend to be
how can I put it a little haphazard
sometimes in our antibiotic usage it
will be very difficult to actually
reverse from where we are current
situated so that's why we need new
antibiotics to actually try to overcome
those those current patterns next
question is there any significant
relation between air pollution and see a
PB ok I think that's an interesting
environmental question I think if you've
considered a asthma and copd are both
our risk factors with regard to
developing see abv then I think we
understand that there is an environment
of influence in both of those conditions
so indirectly I guess there is a
relationship between see a BP and the
environment and I guess it would be
quite interesting to compare the
epidemiological phenomena in areas of
the world where an air pollution is much
more of an issue than other parts of the
world I'm not really going to try and
point fingers but I think it would be
interesting to do those sort of of
analyses I think it rest assured that
the and the pneumonia rates and I can
speak to this because I'm British and
the pneumonia rates in London in the
1950s were somewhat home and the rates
of the ammonia today and I think you
know if one considers the the air
quality changes in the intervening 50
years then I think you know cleaner area
is a better prognosis altogether thank
you
dr. two laps next question is pen still
not resist it with SPM okay penicillin
resistance and the pneumococcus is still
a problem and depending where you are in
the world it is more of a problem there
are two basically types of penicillin
resistance this what we call
intermediate or full
penicillin-resistant a penicillin
resistance effects of a wide range of
the beta lactam family the changes that
go on or within what's called a
bacterial cell wall which is where
penicillin and similar drugs exert their
activity so I think it's really quite
and it's quite interesting that in the
last I guess 20 years we've seen what
appears to be an apparent decrease in
beta lactam penicillin resistance but in
fact what it really relates to is the
lead the way in which we assess
resistance through something called a
break point this is not a situation to
describe that but penicillin resistance
amongst pneumococcus is still an issue
and I think I show up fairly early on in
my presentation the resistance to
ceftriaxone which although it's not
twenty-five percent is still at a level
where one that would consider you know
the empirical approaches of some of
those drugs so the pneumococcus isn't is
a formidable opponent and never
underestimate the pneumococcus its
antibiotic resistance uniform across the
USA
so I'm not sure if you heard the
question is antibiotic resistance
uniform across the USA the answer is no
and if you take the streptococcus
pneumoniae with regard to microbial
resistance or you look at ecole I and
fluoroquinolone resistance you will see
regional variability I showed you a map
of the US which was using what's called
the CDC census regions there are nine of
those and those are based upon certain
CDC epidemiological studies and you can
see that there are differences between
the Pacific region a mountain region
when you go across the East Coast
different parts of the non-essential
knee and eastern USA now that's talking
just USA you look at Europe there are
major differences between Scandinavian
countries and the Mediterranean
countries going over to Asia you'll see
differences between China Japan and
Thailand so might the point of the line
to make here is resistance is it's not
homogeneous resistance does not stay put
resistance can travel and the
prescribing physician not only should
know their local resistance rates to the
major pathogens scrapping among ecoli
and so forth so I think you know not
only should you know your local
resistance you should be aware if it has
the patient traveled recently now I'm
not expecting primary care Doc's to know
what's going on ending in China but at
least just be aware that something else
may be going on so I hope that answers
your question about on which an alien
resistance can we approval one last
question and dr. to lessen does
antibiotic resistance matter
does antibiotic resistance matter I
could be flippant and say yeah but I
hope in my presentation I showed that
antibiotic resistance contributes to
increased morbidity plus general
sickness he contributes to increase in
mortality more deaths and as I said it
contributes to increased healthcare
costs so I think antibiotic resistance
does matter I would like to once again
thanks dr. glenn's Watson for his
presentation dr. two lessons you have
any final comments for our audience
first of all the lights the audience for
listening to me for the last almost an
hour I hope you found it interesting and
informative and that I tried to put
community-acquired bacterial remoting
into some perspective and the impact
that bacterial resistance is having this
week as we try to manage this this awful
condition so thank you very much candy
for your time and attention thank you
again doctor to lessen wanna remind you
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December 7
2016 you will receive an email from
labyrinth alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye